but as i said we're talking about my
favorite games this week
and for today i chose two games by
the talented um
player from india
pragananda
many of you might have heard about him
uh he's
definitely uh proven to be like
you know just an amazing player um this
past
week there was a
tournament where some of the strongest
players in the world
youth players junior players in the
world were competing against each other
in a tournament
that was called uh kind of uh
that was that took place on chess 24 and
was
um called polgar's challenge
and there were two teams competing
against each other
judith polgar's team and vladimir
kraunic's team the players
supposedly have had coaching sessions
with
many top other top chess players in the
world
and they were ready to compete and then
the winner of this event
the young pragananda actually got the
chance as far as i understood to qualify
and actually will be playing against the
big guys in
in one of the next events held by um
just24 all right without further ado
let's get started with these games so
um in this in this this is a game that
was played between
uh mama zadagonai which is a very strong
female chess player from azerbaijan
against pragananda the game started as
follows
e4 c5 knight f3
knight c6 d4 takes takes knight f6
knight c3 t6 the classical variation of
the sicilian
um so far until we get the e5
actually i always like this line you
know like i remember when i was a kid
i was always struggling to to remember
all the sicilian names
so i mean i would always mess them up
even to this day i feel like
if you're just randomly waking me up and
just be like sabina tell me what is the
name of this
you know sicilian line i i i would
need a little bit of time to think about
it which one it is and maybe i could get
them confused so anyways um
but but anyways so e5
knight b3 so far so good it's it's
pretty much theory
uh and then [ __ ] of e3 [ __ ] of e6
i think uh depending on the mover like
sometimes black actually does castle
here first
but pragananda played bishop e6 and
uh mama zada played bishop e2 sorry
queen e2
and this is kind of an interesting
choice usually knight d5 is a move
that's played here but if you do want to
move the queen queen d2 makes a little
bit more sense
typically that's the location for the
queen uh and then probably black would
have castled
castled and i think the line goes as
follows here
we should be five and then knight b4
and after that black is preparing to
play d5 and equalize
trying to equalize the position
but in the game uh i don't know i i
don't think it was a mouse slip i think
probably she had prepared this line to
play queen e2 in this position
um having the queen there sometimes can
be helpful because
if there's no queen on on d2 you have
the rook
you're kind of just placing the rook
after castling you're just placing the
rope on the file and
trying to stop d5 but maybe also have
pressure on the e5 pawn
so that could have been an interesting
idea uh and the reason
why she played that move and then
obviously castle
a4 and here there was also another game
that was played previously like longer
time
ago in 2017 between sam shankland and
emilio cordova and white played the same
move as
as mamazada and that was 95.
what's the point of this move as i said
this pin happens to be something that's
bothering
um black
and uh it's it's definitely a much
better location for the knight to go
than to have to go to d2
right so um and now we're attacking the
bishop in e6 we're attacking b7
and you have to kind of give it up but
a3 i like this game because it's like a
really nice like you you're having some
attacking ideas
there there's lots of tactics sicilian
games games that are playing in the
sicilian are always
have so much material to that is
possible to be discussed and i thought
oh what a better way to um
to choose the games of the week than to
choose
um you know a game by
someone who has proven to who has done
an amazing job
this week in that poger challenge event
um so b3 and now castle
in the game that was played as i
mentioned between sam shanklin
and emilio cordova emilio chose to play
cordova chose to play queen to a5
um the point attacking the knight
obviously
i mean now um that knight is attacked as
well so if you take here for example
i think it would be a mistake because of
queen takes c3
and and the point is that this knight is
still hanging you don't really have many
places to go
so if you think that you're going to be
able to win some material here
we can go king of f8 and you cannot
really take i mean this is kind of
important to realize knight b4 is the
idea
we want knight takes a2 and queen b2
mate if you move the rook wherever
somewhere
um
maybe check you have to go king d1 king
here
loses to mate and then maybe just knight
takes
e4 and the point is that after pawn
takes
bg5
and uh there's no better way for ryden
to sacrifice the queen after which
clearly black should be winning
taking in in e6 does not work so here
black as i said attacked those two
knights this one with the queen and this
one with the pawn because we're escaping
the pin then
the knight has to go to a4 and then
castle
uh and that specific game continued king
b1
knight d4 bishop takes d4
you're kind of forced bishop d7
and you know eventually sam
was able to win this game but um
only after some mistakes by by black and
an interesting game that maybe you guys
want to check later but
queen e5 is certainly an idea but
pragananda
just thought okay i'm not gonna go for
queen a5 i'm just going to castle
make sure i finish my development first
white doesn't have an easy way to attack
black's king just yet
i think he's a she's a little bit behind
like with this g4 g5 idea
she does have 95 eventually but right
now
you know black is the one who seems to
have
created a little bit more pressure on
white skin
uh and so white chose to move the knight
immediately i think in my opinion since
you've wasted the time to bring in the
knight here
i think it's kind of important for white
to take even after pawn takes there's
not
no outpost there anymore
i have some idea like this has happened
once in a game that i played against
arena crush
and she's she has created this weakness
for herself
in a sicilian and i was able to really
take advantage of that weakness
i think if you're not able to prepare d5
that pawn will stay weak and i can try
to take advantage of it
eventually so you know and besides why
it moved that night so many times right
it was knight f3 94 93 knight c5 and now
you're gonna move it again
at least take that [ __ ] up get
something for the fact that you've
wasted so much time
but she played knight a4 probably
thinking
about making sure her king is safe and
then having ideas to place a piece
in b6 and
here uh knight b4 is something that was
actually
tried in another game uh at some point
between uh vukovic and pogbar
two players were not you know so strong
like around 2000 level
but it seems to have happened before
but after this move white played bishop
c5
and now um d5 was the move played in
that game
and after e takes d5
this uh white was able to to get a much
better position okay eventually that
game ended in a draw but white should be
much better here because
they have you know um
big initiative and potentially staying
with extra material
but instead of that knight takes a2
and rook takes a4 considering that if
you take that
you know that is hanging
a line could continue as follows
queen c7 i think black has uh black has
certainly
compensation for the exchange and
it's certainly a type of position that
that one
could play but
this move didn't occur in the game
between mama jada and pragananda
in this scheme instead pragananda played
bishop d7
which seems a little bit strange i mean
really it seems a little bit strange it
feels like
he may have wanted to play knight d7 but
instead with a bishop like a mouth slip
i'm not sure if that was the case but it
seems a little bit strange
in a way you do have some idea to move
the knight
and then try to take in a4 maybe but it
just seems a little bit strange to just
move the bishop from there
because you're controlling d5 and stuff
it seemed a bit strange to me when i
looked at the game
queen d2 obviously the queen is not
necessarily there anymore to take
advantage of the
d file so he went queen to d2 uh
she went queen to d2 and now um
knight d4 bishop takes d4
pawn takes d4 queen takes d4 it seems
like white has a really good position
because
of some waste of time by black um but
what i like from here on is how black
was trying to slowly improve the
position
and of course with the help of white at
some point he was able to win
to win the game here queen e5
you see black has managed despite the
fact that he lost material
he has managed to create some uh
play on the queen side by pushing that
pawn forward
keeping white's king you know a little
bit weak uh try to make a lot of moves
to temple during which time white hasn't
been able to do anything on the king
side which is
something you usually want to do you
want to attack the other side right when
it's opposite side castling
one person is attacking on one side of
the board on your king
the other one meaning you probably are
attacking on the other one but
here it didn't quite happen and now
you have to be careful of various ideas
you want knight b6 which i like rogue d8
and here for some reason she played
knight c4
she's made a little bit too many knight
moves
in my opinion white
b4 is a very interesting choice here for
white
the point being if you check are we just
go king b1
the king will be totally safe there
there's considering that these pawns are
you know far from each other far from
protecting each other and now with the
queen in g5 there will be there will be
ideas with h4
you know g4 g5 white can start pushing
the pawns now and black doesn't have
anything
doesn't have attacking ideas whatsoever
this knight in b6 is doing an amazing
job
and um you know just controlling
the c file the a file so black doesn't
have
a way for the rook to get to be on a
better location to attack
and uh and you don't have an easy way to
do things if you move the knight to play
bishop f6
this pawn will be hanging so it just
seems very tough and plus
white has an extra pawn but from here on
step by step
the position of black starts improving
queen c7 played queen b6
now he did not take trade he played
queen to c8
if queen takes b6 knight takes b6 i
think this position is once again much
better for white
usually end games are supposed to be
better for black
in from the sicilian from the sicilian i
have to
be clear on that a lot of sicilian end
games are supposed to be better or
at least equal from the perspective of
black
i cannot say from black's perspective if
it's equal but anyways
but in this case it's different because
white has an extra pawn and
there are quite some weaknesses in
black's uh
side so this would make it kind of
impossible
in my opinion for them to save
themselves knight c4 is an idea that one
will be falling
it should be bad so he did not want to
trade queens he's still
trying to have the opportunity to play
some d5
white did not want to be greedy but i
think greedy could have worked here
knight takes here d5
for example if you you're trying um
white can bring in the knight and if
you're trying to take
here or something we can go bishop c4
blacks has some attack but
not really much of the c file white's
extra pawn is
is an extra pawn and seems to be pretty
good there's i don't really see a way
for black to have to get sufficient
compensation
instead queen b4 was played
and now queen to c7 may be kind of a
strange decision because
you can still try to trade the queens
which is what she did
but black no and try again
no and no until
black because you know he's a stronger
player he decided not to repeat anymore
but you always have to be careful
this is something i'm always telling my
students depending on the situation of
the tournament depending on the game
please don't let yourself influenced by
the rating of the opponent
play the position you have on the board
if your opponent
is much stronger obviously you know um
you are okay with the draw if your
opponent is much weaker obviously you're
not
okay with the draw but it doesn't mean
you have to to force things
because often times when we force things
we get to have
to to fall for you know worse positions
and actually we could end up losing so
please
please be very careful with the
decisions you are making because it is
possible
that you mess up now here pragmata
didn't quite mess up
he still has a balanced position with
the move that he chose to play not to
repeat with queen c6
so that was good but in some situations
a lot of us make this mistake
we really really wanted to find a way to
beat our opponent because we feel that
we should win because we are
stronger on paper um but
but that's when we we make the mistake
so anyways he played queen e6
now white doesn't have a way to treat
the queen and now he
is thinking to improve the position of
his knight like this we shall maybe
going to f6
and you'll see what else happened next
to knight d7
white is retreating the queen because
obviously there was a threat of
of d5 at d5 at some point so that's why
the queen kind of had to go away from
there
now knight c5
and in this position white had the bad
timing at taking the pawn
although in the beginning a few moves
ago i told you it was fine
here it it's not as fine to take and
you'll see what happened in the game
knight b6 maybe would have
been better because after this now they
can play the ninth place the ninth year
so this move is never possible
and then if needed at some point c3 is
an option
white can proceed with the development
and
just having the c file is not enough for
black to create any counter play
but white took there instead allowing
black to play d5 and take advantage of
the
default the king had to go back i mean
he didn't have to but he played there
and now a very very interesting
idea played by pragananda was
knight takes two e4 very interesting
idea
and white fell for the capture of the
knight
it is very difficult i think to come up
with something else obviously
that knight is hanging but you can think
of this
move and maybe now bishop here could
happen
and then i don't know the knight would
retreat
so his black got to win a pawn but
most likely white is better but instead
mama zada took bishop takes a3
and now she made a decision after which
things are things are tough for white
she played bishop b5
she has to try to finish her development
indeed that bishop hasn't moved and
where moved
30 so that's certainly you know big
no for white but white did win some
material so
sometimes you can afford to make these
kind of mistakes
maybe e5 would have been an option
and then in case of f6 you can always
protect that pawn like this
and you will keep attacking and then
maybe now bishop b5 because you're
actually making the movie temple
it's always important to do so and after
this
threatening mate and forcing the trade
sure okay we'll trade
the queens you don't have any other
option and we can do this and
obviously why shouldn't take is it's
helping black get the pawns to better
look
a bit better placed but this position
should be
kind of equal you know material is equal
opposite color bishops
black has a weakness but white stays on
a background mate
so pretty equal i would say but this
move was played instead
and then d takes e4 c3
to try to avoid you know mason the
diagonal probably
but now after c3 what do we notice the
second rank
becomes weak in some situations you can
consider that
and now b5 so step by step black is
improving both players have made
mistakes let's not forget this was a
rapid
tournament i think it was like 10
minutes plus some some increment i
forgot the exact time control i keep
checking it but i keep forgetting it
not sure if it's written on my
thing no it's not written
uh now b4 would have been a nice choice
for black
trying to you know taking c3 win
win an upon
black played here instead obviously no
trade
so yeah queen back bishop takes b5
and now you push the pawn and here maybe
maybe white after rookie one could have
tried to hold on to the position once
again because now if you trade
trade um
you we cannot push further because
rookie 1 and the pawn will be lost
so it's definitely a difficult position
i would say here
okay queen of three
rook takes the one rook takes d1 queen
e5
and here you would say the black has no
compensation seriously black has
really literally no compensation but
pragananda got lucky in this game
in a way you know i chose the game
because i i thought it was like great
uh great chances for both sides program
that did win the tournament so you have
to show a little bit
uh support for that in the same way it's
a female which i like
uh she has an amazing game unfortunately
she
blundered it happens later
uh but also um
it's always a fight right you see
opposite side castling you see attacks
on both sides you see an end game even
bishop back here
rook d5 look how great you played this
part of the game white played really
well
uh queen e6 and now bishop d3 that pawn
is stopped
i think instead of bishop d3 had she
played maybe bishop here
it's going to be kind of difficult for
black to find a
good location for the queen because that
pawn in e3 will be lost and then
with those three connected past pawns
over here white has big big chances
to to win i mean definitely
but she played bishop d3 and now
she started weakening her position a
little bit c4
after rookie age she blundered she
played rookie bishop e2 thinking that
she had to stop that pawn
but now had black played queen a6 it's
going to be difficult to defend
because the queen enters on the dark
squares which you cannot protect
given that all your pawns are on white
and that queen is on the other side of
the board
but okay both players were really low on
time so both kind of made some mistakes
here
and then um
probably nerves who knows
white played this move c5
after which you know it's going to be
game over queen d6 probably would have
worked
for white just trying to trade the
queens um
and if you're not trading maybe you can
try to kind of hold on to the position
like this and then queen before
the point is you're trying to cover the
dark square so that black cannot
get the queen active and have mating
ideas
but c5 was played and now
why not queen a6 instead of queen b6
if queen a6 here a4 is an option
and then you know if you're trying to
enter like that
that would be i think queen here still
with temple followed by 26
and white is able to cover the dark
squares you don't have an entrance
so now this is the issue
that although white is trying to promote
that that c pawn
now the queen enters and it's really
tough
back check
and white resigns because now the bishop
is hanging
and it's game over so i felt that this
was kind of like a hard-fought game from
both sides
definitely pragananda you know got lucky
in the end
um throughout he had an interesting
position he equalized at some point but
then
he's made some mistakes letting white
just very active but nerves are also
very important in such a tournament
and it's something you have to be
careful for my next game is also a game
played by pragananda this time against
another
talented and famous grandmaster
and from india nihal sarin
so both of these players are really
really strong and
i think we can expect a lot from them in
the future
so definitely keep an eye on them i
chose
this uh this win by pragananda as i said
he did win
the event so it was only fair to choose
some of his wins this was
a different kind of opening uh
here transposing into a queen's gambit
declined 1997 bishop f4 queen's gambit
declined with bishop f4
um all right and here um
d takes e4 was played i think this is
like more of a modern approach
uh before people were more playing like
c6
in this position some people would try
bishop b4 but this is
something displayed um dxe4 is played
more these days
so that line is like this i think bishop
e7 bishop d3
castle castle and then in this position
black can play the d takes e4 to take
advantage of the fact that white moved
the bishop so they have to move it again
or uh b6 so both choices are possible
and usually what happens white takes
here goes queen c2
uh bishop b7 rook d1 and
you know game goes on knight e5 is an
idea for white
this this idea goes way back way back to
maybe pillsbury
pillsbury's time where 95 this bishop
would move away and then f4 ideas
so definitely an old line that um
that many of you could or could not know
uh of course after castle d takes c4 is
an option two
and they used to play in the old days
bishop takes c4 b5 the bishop would go
back either b3 or d3 usually
um and or e2 actually e2
uh as well pretty famous variation and
then bishop on b7
or a6 and then black would try to play
c5 right
a6 eventually also has to be played
whether you played first or bishop b7
but then play b uh sorry c5 attack the
center and
black would try to have a nice idea but
in the game black
chose to play d takes c4 instead not c6
to defend first he just supposed to take
immediately
now e3 because obviously we need to get
the pawn back and
black played b5
um knight d5 is the other line
here for black the idea is that you know
you cannot take a spawn takes but you do
need to take
your pawn back uh but because the bishop
is in f4
when you take here black and take the
bishop
and then knight b6
followed by g6 and you know
or bishop b7 depends what you do
v6 or e7 and
you know the position is pretty balanced
i like this i i think this is pretty
nice for black instead
black play b5 in this position
knight takes b5 obviously you know white
is trying to get their pawn back
check knight c3
nakamura played this against carlson as
well
it's in line and wesley still played it
i didn't learn played it many of the top
players did play this line it's
it's a pretty known line knight to d5
still with a similar idea put the
pressure on c3 and on the bishop
now white kinda has to play a3
knight takes c3 ambition kick c3 is an
option
and then knight takes f4 pawn takes f4
knight b6 this is an option for black
trying to stay
um you know on top keep the c4 pawn
protected but
um it doesn't quite work because
technically white can still take it
after takes check and takes the knight
and white
actually stays with an extra pawn
so that's the reason why this position
black usually ends up taking with the
knight
and here you cannot get your your piece
back if you take with the pawn bishop
takes
if you take them the bishop the queen
hangs so please don't make the blunder
you're technically
giving up a piece here temporary but
there's nothing to be worried about if
you learn
this move which is queen d2
and the point is that now both pieces
are attacked there's no discovery that's
going to help black
stay with the extra piece the piece will
be carry captured
and now everything will be will be fine
and
in this position there's a well-known
line i mean a lot of people can try to
play knight d5
but then this would happen and then you
know black can take here
here go bishop b7 go knight b6 but
the position is put on unclear with all
of these
double pawns and weaknesses for white
there's so many of them
but um yeah it's quite playable
in the game however and this is
apparently known from
some game that was played between
westeroso and anandi 2016
annan came up with this idea of
sacrificing the bishop in
a3 and people
used to go queen takes c3 that was
basically the
the way things went that was the game
wesley against a nun
and then black would have to return to
the bishop and then we would trade it
pawn takes bishop takes c4
castle and again you know bishop b7
pretty equal a pretty equal position but
instead of queen takes c3
in that position pragalanda came up with
the novelty
pawn takes c3
vision d6
takes takes bishop takes c4
and now um material
is equal but
i think it is a little bit nicer to have
the pawns compact in the center that a
pawn
oftentimes if if you're not able to
support it
somehow that pawn will be weak and
potentially captured and
white can try to step by step fight to
uh to improve the position and
eventually win the game obviously
castle castle before b7
um so once again like you have to look
at that a pawn and think about
if it bothers you if you are white if
it's
like a past far away pawn that can help
you or a weakness
let's see now
for white what do you need to do in this
position
you have to try to think of a plan
clearly you can try to get the space
with the center to prepare to play e4
but then what
this pawn is also a pawn that you have
to be careful for because queen c7 can
come in
four by rook c8 putting pressure you
need to be ready to meet
the pressure on the pawn so program
landed retreated with the bishop in e2
he probably tried to avoid the capture
here as well i don't think that would be
a big deal but
just in case he chose to place his
bishop in e2 not in d3
trying to bring the bishop and the queen
on this b1a
h7 diagonal is not that big of a deal
because
they can always defend it so easily even
with knight f6
and you can't do so much so you're not
in a big rush here
c4 a5
and now rook f
to c1 so progrananda is
improving the position of his pieces
like i said he's not so worried about
that a pawn
black has to try to push it obviously
because that's his
strong suit but but you cannot push it
too much the more you push it if you
don't have a way for your minor pieces
to defend it
that pawn is going to turn out to be a
weakness
here black made a luft make sure he
doesn't stay on the background mate ever
and now queen c3 this move may seem a
little bit
strange but this
idea of moving the queen is to free the
d2 square which is a typical
square for the knight in a lot of d4
openings
so you're maneuvering the knight to d2
to support e4 maybe f3
if needed and bringing the knight to a
better location or bringing it
on the other side of the board to attack
um to attack the e5 pawn this is a very
tricky position
indeed it's not something uh very clear
it's not
so clear that what your plans are with
both sides so
it's nice to see games uh like this
because
the more games you see the more ideas
come to your mind and
you will know how to approach similar
similar games in the future
or similar ideas and here
um black probably can play bishop c6
or or try to push the pawn 24 because he
can support it with the knight
in b6 the bishop in c6 we need g7 if
needed he probably should push it also
doesn't allow 93
but instead black played e5
which is not really such a necessary
move because
it opens this diagonal and white
immediately took advantage of it bishop
g4
pinning the knight now we may want to
take at some point
maybe win a pawn not yet because after
uh takes pawn takes if we take in d7
queen takes take
the knight will be hanging in the end so
we need to make sure the knight is
protected and then we'll see further
what do we do
obviously obviously pawn takes back
right
and here black made a mistake
he should have as i said push this pawn
definitely
white can make some error something with
h3 then
go bishop d1 and try to take the pawn
but in the same time black can try to
improve the position of his pieces
go on the a file bring in the knight to
f6
try to play queen c6 to take advantage
of the weakness in g2
just tried to make some mozi temple
basically but instead he played rookie
and this is a mistake the reason
it's a mistake is because white did have
a threat after bishop g4
their threat was
to to take the knight and then this pawn
would be hanging
yes so as i said the plans for black
would have been instead of the e5
to play um
a4 or organic f6 to try to
to go there and then maybe bishop c6
that bishop definitely needs to be
both on the um a8 h1 diagonal or there
push a4 and then it's
just try to support that pawn
and and as you play you know white makes
ideas comes up with plans as well plants
can change
each time and then you can readjust
the situation but that is something kind
of important that pawn
could be weak and you have to place it
on a square where it makes it more
difficult for the opponent to attack it
and wean it
instead he plays rook e8 and after
bishop takes d7
queen takes d7 rook takes a5 white
basically um
f4 f5 knot that's not such a great idea
for white not here the rook is on
there's no more rook here to to attack
the side of the board so you don't want
to start pushing that pawn
with your pieces on the other side of
the board uh
also the position is not located so
usually when it's not
you have to be careful how you're
pushing your pawns you don't want to
start pushing
pawns like that at random weakening your
king
for no reason so here
rook takes a5 and in this position um
mihaw sarin probably thought that
he could have some drawing idea and
blundered bishop takes g2 it was
probably a tactical oversight i guess
he thought that after king takes rook
takes a5
queen takes a5 he has this check
and then if if white plays here he would
have a draw
or something i don't know but white
obviously had king h1 and that now
there's no check
so it is not clear to me exactly what he
thought
maybe he thought he takes a lot of
material maybe he thought rookie two but
it's not
really whatever move black chooses to
play here it's not really giving
them much chance to get much so he took
here
and since we have extra material an
extra night
we're totally fine with the trade of the
queens obviously
black is not he's trying to take more
pawns in order to try to equalize we're
threatening rookie two as well
and white was able to take control
and attack
now queen a7 would have been an option
but then the knight comes in i think
knight h4 knight f5 extra knight
it's hard to beat black had this idea in
mind
and let's see if you guys find
a good move for white in this position
in the game white uh
gave this check that maybe it wasn't the
wisest
thing to do but um it is more
technical i think to trade rooks go king
g2
and then kg1 you've got a couple more
checks then there's knight f1
if you give me this check then i can go
king um
king of one and i'm trying to hide away
on the other side of the board
if queenie won knight f1 that's the idea
and i don't know if you guys know but
knights are usually the best pieces to
protect the king against the
queen checks so that this could make it
safe instead white went for this check
and then queenie for check kind of a
crazy tactical idea just hanging the
queen
thinking okay you kind of have to take
rook takes and
maybe black thought that he should be
able to hold on
in this position because he saw rudy
four and he probably thought he can
somehow trade those two pawns
and then you know it's not possible
queen and uh
sorry rook and knight to to win so
easily that's
was probably in his mind but what
happened is like any d5
white can push t5 as well why does it
need to trade
and now it's an end game so white
brought in the king towards the center
and i really like that technique
of white is almost lost
um king e2 v5 and now it's kind of an
interesting choice
probably h3 is a little bit better to
stop g4
but it's a brilliant it's a really
really interesting idea and
thankfully for them i mean the idea is
amazing actually to come this way and
support
and trap the rook uh but but if this
were
gonna happen it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be a big deal but
what happened in the game is that here
after king to d1
black blundered he played king g3 and
now what happened
black's rook stayed trapped there's not
so much that they could do about it
and what did white do
obviously just king c2
i even made a rhyme and now
the king c3 is the is the threat and
the the rook is kind of trapped so
black's only chance to free up the
rookies to play f3 to have the
opportunity to move it there but
with that move you're giving another
pawn and now it makes it more difficult
for him to save to stay safe
here h3 and the rest is just a matter of
technique so
g4 was played trying to trade pawns is
definitely in black's favor
because rook knight vs rook is supposed
to be a draw i think i said that already
i've uh if you guys are watching me
stream for twitch
you probably have seen me play that
recently i tried to win it but
it's usually a pretty easy defense i
would say for the rook
rook d3 h5 because you cannot protect
that pawn and after taking this pawn
this is a pass pawn that should help
white win the game just definitely not
do not blunder it
he played here g3 king e3
the pawn was pushed
i'm just showing you how he's making
sure that
uh black's rook is kind of trapped there
in g3 he's trying to make sure he does
not lose that pawn that pawn is super
important for
for white why should not never lose that
pawn
and then you're trying to chase the rook
away so that you're winning the inch
pawn and that's exactly
what happened the rook went to here and
now
it's kind of as i said a matter of
technique because that one is protected
and all you have to do is change black's
king away and then just start pushing
the pawn
here here
faded the rooks and then the end game
was won
sorry the end game was winning and black
resigned
so these were basically the two games of
pragananda that i wanted to show for
today
i felt that that was a very important
and interesting tournament
i don't know if you guys watched it
there are lots of lots of interesting
games
i chose these two for now because i
thought you know
here's the winner definitely a player to
look forward to
to see what the future holds for him
um and
as you can see top players make mistakes
as well strong players grandmasters
they make mistakes as well as not just
us um
when they attack you know everyone
everyone can make make a mistake
um you have to be careful you have to
learn
when to be great greedy when not to be
greedy
um and that's that that's that
i wonder if any of you have questions i
saw a couple of questions
on the stream but they are not really
related to what i was doing
so i will try my best to answer one of
them
uh if i know some rubinstein book i'm
not sure which one you're talking about
so are you talking about the ending one
the the rubenstein end game book that
one is a good one actually if that's the
one you're talking about that's
a pretty good book if you can find it i
don't know maybe you can find it celery
stress club may have it on their site or
if you're in san luis you can go check
out the club and see
i remember they used to have it there if
not you're gonna always check
uscf sales and
if you're in the united states if not
um i don't know check out some some
chess chess stores and uh and i'm sure
you can
eventually find a book it is a nice book
within games
uh le sheets in book
of end games was very very good um
forex and game manual is good for
players over 2200
and salemans and game course i think is
called is also a good ending book that
you may want to
work on
[Music]
i don't know if there's another question
[Music]
i think i answered i think i answered
most of your questions guys i don't know
if there's anything that i didn't answer
i hope you guys liked my choices of
today they're not like
brilliant games or anything but i think
there were interesting games with
with ideas on both sides um tactical
ideas are easily missed by everyone
don't forget about psychology just
don't forget about making sure you take
your
you make your decisions based on the
position not your opponent's rating
[Music]
check out tactics all the time if you
have a past pawn far away
remember that can be a weakness too
that's exactly what happened in this
last game
for black he had that a pawn pass then
he probably thought
that pawn is just so amazing but it
turned out to be a weakness so just
because if
it's a far away past pawn it doesn't
mean that your opponent
now will not do anything he'll be super
happy
um and um and that's it
uh he will resign nobody will resign
they will play
they will play and that pawn yourself
proved to be a weakness
i don't know if there's any other
questions
i don't see any other questions from you
guys
i think i will finish here this
uh this video i really hope you guys
enjoyed my choices of the day
please do subscribe for san luis chess
clubs
youtube channel they're definitely
lots of interesting videos
showing every single day you wouldn't
want to miss being subscribed
to the channel helps you
be notified when we go live what videos
we're posting
and anything on that matter
the club is also streaming
on twitch that's another place that you
may want to follow the club uh
check out the social media as well just
to
be on track with tournaments over the
board tournaments may come soon so
it'd be great to to see some of you
there
and um
without further ado i wish you all a
wonderful evening
or morning depending on where you are
and i hope to see you
in future videos uh on sunday
actually i'm not sure i better not say
anything
i'm looking forward to seeing you in
future videos enjoy your day
bye for now